so travis you and i talked before and
you know the world knows you from
television they don't know all the other
stuff you did but you've had security
clearances high-level doing work for
different agencies for a long time
yeah i started working uh for the army
uh gosh i was 17 actually and i've been
a scientist for or an engineer for the
army ever since there's a a about seven
years in my life where i
went into private sector and worked for
the intelligence community as a
contractor and then i went back into
civil service and
i've been doing that
my whole life and i've had a security
clearance for decades did you need
permission to be
the scientist on tv
oh yeah in fact
before i uh was on tv i also write
science fiction novels and i remember my
first science fiction novel they made me
give it to security and they went
through it to make sure that there
wasn't anything that was uh too close to
what i was doing at work or that might
be sensitive in nature uh and uh and
after about my third or fourth novel
they it was too much work for them so
they quit worrying about it did you have
to tell them hey this is the parameters
for what i'm gonna do on television i'll
be the scientist and i'll be a debunker
if necessary and every single time um uh
i would go on tv or as a any kind of
news uh uh
appearance or anything like that i would
always tell them you know i'm doing this
i'm going to say uh things and and uh
depending on which legal person they had
me talk to
uh
at each time what i was told i could and
couldn't say was different
every time they didn't really have a a
good standard they just don't don't say
anything you're not giving an official
a dod
statement you're given a travis taylor
private citizen statement
and that's typically how i always
treated it and
in some cases i could say i worked for
dod then it would change their mindset
no you work for the army and then no
don't say army just say defense uh
industry
when you started working at skinwalker
we've talked about this before you were
an arch skeptic you were skeptical about
some of the weird stuff that had gone on
there correct my my actual uh
notion was that there were some bad
actors
doing some things uh maybe it was
russian maybe it was chinese maybe it
was just some uh kids with some new toys
uh or maybe even the skinwalker uh
people were uh doing something to sell
books and tv shows bigelow yeah maybe
bigelow even were you aware about awsap
and that program when you started
working on the on the ranch uh when i
started working on the ranch i uh had i
knew there were
programs but i didn't know exactly who
was doing it and what and i had been
trying to reach out to them for a while
uh
and figure it out and i actually wrote a
book
on uh on how you would defend the planet
if there was an alien invasion and that
there should be an actual organization
preparing uh and studying possibilities
and i detailed out what that
organization would be like using my
defense knowledge defense industry
knowledge and how those things work and
i find out later
that
the organizations that were created were
uh uh almost just like the chapter in my
book that describes it and
and uh uh jay stratton's uh he actually
has a copy of the book and it's used it
so did you have any idea that you would
eventually work for the kind of program
that you were describing well uh when i
when i wrote the book i i uh i always
said in public but this is my resume
anybody out there that's doing this work
i'll be happy to help can you talk to me
about the day that somebody came and
asked and you took took you up on that
offer
it was uh it was really interesting uh
so some of the things that happened at
skinwalker ranch um i was in
early 2019
i i was concerned that they might have
had defense uh
national security issues involved with
it so i uh asked for a meeting with some
folks at the pentagon that i reached out
through mutual colleagues and i went and
briefed them on some of the information
and then at the time
they said they checked my clearances and
all and we were talking in a room where
we could talk uh you know national
security uh things
and uh at that it was at that point
where i was invited to join the team
in what capacity
well at first i wasn't wasn't sure but
within a couple of weeks
jay stratton the director of the uap
task force asked me if i would be
interested in being the chief scientist
and i was like yeah absolutely of course
i would i mean you're the chief
scientist for the uav task force and
you're the guy as the scientist on
skinwalker ranch people's heads are
going to explode but they realize that
yeah
and you know there's nothing i wasn't
hiding anything from anybody we weren't
sure of the sensitivity of of our
positions and and there was uh public
affairs issues you know and there was
also the question of uh
you know are we prepared to handle the
uh the press response and the freedom of
information act response and all these
things it wasn't because it was all
cloak and dagger you know do you find it
as at all a conflict of those two roles
you're working for the uap task force
looking at big picture stuff and then
being specific to the ranch
um is it you ever have trouble wearing
two hats at the same time well while i
was uh so i'm recently retired from the
government and i'm working in a private
uh company now but uh while i was doing
i had to be real careful not to violate
either ndas the ndas that i had with the
with brandon fugle and the history
channel
at skinwalker ranch and the ndas with
with the government
but what i did was uh it was mutually uh
beneficial to both parties because i
understood bigger picture stuff from
being with the government and then i
also got to be in the laboratory
hands-on at skinwalker ranch and both of
them were very important